The joe rogan experience.
Yeah,
you,
you become,
you don't trust in the way you view things anymore.
You're boxed in.
It's very dangerous to be committed to something you know,
is not true.
It also shows it a lot too because when he got these geniuses who spent their
entire lives doing too in this stuff and astrophysics,
you're telling me that they're part of the scheme to,
and they believe that it's,
you know,
this is 100% of the problem.
100%.
It's adopting an idea too soon.
That's 100% of the idea because once you,
once you adopt that idea and then you hang on to it,
now you're fucked.
Like big foot mat.
Big Foot was a big one for me.
I was,
I was convinced I was real with you.
How long ago was this?
A couple of weeks now when I
not when I know to you.
Um,
yeah man,
when I did this TV show,
that's when I totally let it go.
I'd kind of let it go before then,
but Duncan and I actually went to the Pacific northwest and we went to hang out
with like real big foot experts.
It was searching for big foot all the time.
When you say real big foot at x,
what you mean con artists?
No,
it's not that way.
I described him as unfuckable white dudes who have nothing to do.
There's just,
they're just a bunch of fellows.
We decided to call ourself a rap band.
We're going to call ourselves a UFW D fuckable white.
You didn't find in out there in Pacific fighting shit,
fat camp spots.
A lot of spent shells and beer cans laying around.
You're better than that Joe.
No,
this is what I found out.
People want to believe in things and once you want to believe in something
instead of looking at it objectively and going,
wow,
I'm not sure you like automatically go towards any information that would point
to the fact that the thing is real,
not to the whole body of information.
Look well how crazy these people when you meet the people that believe in
bigfoot,
the blends that have seen it,
the ones that had claimed to scene it,
almost all of 'em were clearly lying in a law in a little like out of it let it
was one lane spectrum maybe.
Yeah,
but it just,
some people are just liars.
They can't help it.
They make stories up to make themselves feel better.
Like they just crazy and you,
you,
you can't really say it to their face cause you don't really know.
But sometimes it just gets ridiculous.
And this one lady was one of the only ones that didn't seem like that.
This one lady was telling me a story about how she was going through the woods
and she saw some big thing that was standing up and it was like seven feet tall
and it was moving through the woods and uh,
she saw this thing and she was like,
oh my God,
it's an ape.
And then she realized it was big foot and she saw it for a few steps and then it
was gone.
At the time I was fascinated at the time I was like,
maybe she really did see it,
but now I know for a fact,
an absolute fact that where she lived,
there's a lot of black bears and black bears will often walk on their hind legs.
They'll walk like big foot.
They really do.
There's many,
many,
many videos.
I've seen it with my own two eyes.
I saw a bear walked for several,
like six,
seven,
maybe even 10 steps on its hind legs roaring at another bear.
And they were going to fight with each other and they fought with Joe standing
up.
They went after each other dope.
But dude,
he walked towards him like that.
Look at that does look like they do that.
So that bear,
this is a bear that had injured pause and sometimes they'll get their pod bid
off in a fight.
They Duke it out with each other or maybe they get caught in a trap.
You know,
some fucking assholes.
It set traps out there for the forced to walk like that.
They buy back their own foot off to get out of a trap then that's real man.
They,
they,
they get wolves that way.
They catch them and traps [inaudible] traps are scary shit.
But these animals,
you know when they get a hurt paw they'll walk on their back legs like big foot.
So she probably saw some shit moving through the woods.
Like community shit.
Yeah Dude,
they just stand there.
That's terrifying.
I know.
And they can walk like that.
That's terrifying.
But it's clearly not a fucking big fight.
You Moron.
No,
no,
no.
See you say that.
But Dude,
I'm telling you when you're in the Pacific northwest,
you cannot see 15 yards in front of you.
Dunkin and I were talking about it,
cause you know we had a hang out up there and go wandering through the woods
where like if there was something right there,
like five trees away and then it moved into the back,
how long would it take for disappeared through steps.
Three steps.
It's so dense,
dude.
It's like a Q tip box.
You know,
you get q-tips out of a box.
So many of them,
this is no gaps in between these trees.
Have you been to the Pacific northwest?
I'm the rain forest and I've ever been in there.
I mean I was drunk,
drove through it.
It's amazing.
And here's the other thing about it.
It's all pine needles so that you don't even make any noise.
But I would see a standing figure like that in,
in my educated Bray.
And I go,
oh that's a fucking giant bear.
No,
because you'd be looking at a hill like a hundred yards away.
And he would see this thing walk through the tree standing up.
And you'd be like,
what in the fuck was that?
And then it's gone.
So then your imagination starts running wild and your imagination starts filling
in the blanks.
I don't think it's a coincidence.
The higher none for sure.
Your high,
well then I'd probably think you're in Seattle,
man.
Okay,
then why would you not be high?
But you're eating mushrooms.
Your highest fuck all on shrooms.
Everybody up there on terms and that's a walking Brown Unicorn.
You're walking down this road in the forest and you see something that's in the
woods and you see it briefly a hundred yards away for three or four steps.
Your brain starts filling in the blanks and you get excited.
You saw fucking big foot and I will go to my grave knowing what I saw that day
and everybody wants to be special,
so everybody wants to pretend he saw a giant monkey in the woods,
but when you really talk to them,
that was the only lady I knew that wasn't lying to me.
She saw something she has.
She thought it was big for shit.
It was standing.
If I had a guess,
if I had some money to bet,
I would bet almost 100% what she saw was a bear.
You did the show and after coming back from that show you like,
you know what big foot's bullshit and it's the same feeling I got talking to
everybody.
Psychic readers,
same feeling.
Got talking to UFO experts.
Same feeling.
I got to,
everybody wants to believe everybody wants to do you a full I can.
Flux with the Ufo makes sense to me.
This,
there's so many kind of sure you x factors there.
I can buy a u f so it could be real.
It could be real big flood.
Come on.
Here's the thing about big foot.
The reason why it's so attractive is because it used to be a real animal.
100% it was a thing called gigantic [inaudible].
They didn't know about gigantic Pythagoras until I believe it was the 1920s they
found a tooth of this primate in an apothecary shop in China and they were like,
what the fuck is this it?
Yeah.
They were selling it and someone found another tooth and they said,
oh,
there's another,
and the the primatologist who check it out that that was a real animal cod.
Yeah.
Tog
eight foot tall,
gigantic orangutan looking thing.
It still doesn't look like a human.
And they rang Tang family.
No,
no,
no dude,
it doesn't,
well,
big foot's supposed to look like that.
Oh really?
Supposed to look like.
Yeah.
It's not supposed to be where you're human was like a hero.
There's a photo of a man standing next to a proportionate man.
The average size man standing next to which I can't go pick his statue.
See if you could find that in there.
I know it's in there.
Pick up this [inaudible].
Yeah,
that's it.
That was how big it was.
So that was a real animal.
100% now they're not 100% sure that it walked on two legs,
but they're pretty sure.
And the reason why is the shape of the teeth,
that animals that walk on their hind legs,
animals that walk upright have a different shape to their jaw.
So that's what they've found.
It looks like you found a job bone and they found some teeth and they found it
like all on the same site,
and then they realize that they're dealing with a totally different animal.
He was around how long ago?
10,000 years ago.
So this thing existed somewhere in the neighborhood of,
I think that's right.
Wait a minute,
that might be wrong.
I think I'm thinking of the Flores man was the hobbit man,
the little three foot tall dude.
That dude was like 10 14,000 years ago.
That was really soon.
Yeah.
Like really recently.
Definitely lived alongside people.
This might be 100,000.
What makes it attractive though is where that thing lived is exactly where all
the animals cam across the Bering land bridge that connected Asia to North
America.
So this Bering land bridge was where they think everything came across.
Short face bear,
even people.
Okay.